[Music]
talk about Beyonce you know I love her
because she helps so many people that
are in need but you know where she got
that spirit from her mama Tina I saw it
firsthand when the family was in Houston
lending a helping hand to hurricane
Harvey victims and now miss Tina Lawson
has another project so I had to pay her
a visit to talk about that and of course
those gorgeous grandbabies they're doing
great they are absolutely beautiful and
there's so much fun it's so cute I can
hardly take it I'm telling you and I can
only imagine how good blue is whereas
she's such a good big sister Tina's
totally enjoying her second act in life
with husband of two years after Richard
Lawson they first met when Tina was
still married to her first husband and
pregnant with Beyonce now they're
partnering up another way bringing the
arts to underprivileged kids at their
Waco theater Center in Los Angeles what
will happen in here theater music dance
comedy whatever in our hearts desire
this place being a community center
because when my kids were growing up
there was a community center and they
wouldn't be who they are today if they
had not had that Center to go and do all
forms of art you know mama Knowles has
the support of her famous daughters in
this passion project but there's one
thing they wish she wouldn't do if my
kids had their way I wouldn't be on
Instagram I wouldn't be on any social
media oh they hate it what you know what
somebody was away but you know you are
live walking down the street like huh I
don't even know how I knew that I loved
her and people loved her on social media
by the way she has over a million
followers to prove it so just keep on
Miss Tina
[Music]
you